i'm crystal i'm peppermint i'm barbada
but you can call me
hello mothers of call me mother i am
so excited to have this reunion with you
three i had the time of my life
working with the three of you there may
be some people who have no idea what
call me mother is
all about so i need you to kind of break
it down for me
oh my gosh it is um it's a game where
you have to
hide a lot of money up your butt and see
who can find it first
oh i swear i played that before yeah i'm
not on the same show
i'm actually playing that right now hold
on
see i told you we had fun dallas call me
mother is this amazing
drag competition show um where the three
of us
nurture the next generation of drag
talent
we're here to do a job baby let's get it
going we're gonna have the perfect gang
that's ready to attack
yes they really want you come on
we're searching for the first child of
drag and
um it gets a little bit tense at times
but it's a very warm-hearted
and uh beautiful show everyone is going
to get
the feeling of family and attachment and
that's that's what the show is about
watching the show i think people are
going to be pleasantly surprised
um because there's been a calling sort
of a thirst for drag
uh a thirst for different types of drag
rep different representations of drag
and we're going to be able to
show that to people i think what's also
really amazing about this show
is that we're not looking for the person
who can spend the most money on drag
the show really supports artists
it was less about you know forcing
everyone to fit into
what we are trying to do and more about
us sort of
conforming to the style of drag that
they were bringing
barbada both crystal and peppermint uh
appeared on other
drag reality competition series what was
the experience like for you
it's overwhelming to be surrounded by
so many cameras first of all to have a
camera that's
always there like literally always i had
for some reason
a camera in my shower did you guys have
that i don't know oh i put it there
sorry oh okay okay that's fine but no it
was
really really fun it was i learned a lot
and you know what uh
i can't wait for people to see it i've
watched each of you
get so attached to your drag children
how difficult was it to see them leave
week after week each week whether it was
regardless of whose house it's from
it's it's a very intense and emotional
thing because there is a bond
that is is formed and so it really did
in in the short amount of time it became
a family and so seeing these people
and their contributions uh you know
leave the show
um was devastating every single week it
was really unexpected how emotional i
it made me like i did not expect to cry
especially because
my doctor assured me that that would
never happen again
um surgery the soul or the tear duct
removal
i watched the three of you bond behind
that
desk so i want to play a play a quick
little game i'm going to call
motherly love barbada i want to hear
what you loved about working with
someone like crystal
oh my gosh um the fact that she gave me
so much
um so much advice on my makeup like i
literally i remember
being at the desk and taking a picture
of like a close-up of her face
like this clothes from her face because
i wanted to see her makeup
and she was sitting right next to me so
she helped me a lot
going through all those really intense
emotions
when to have when you had you know to
send someone home miss peppermint
tell me what you loved about meeting and
working with barbada
what i love so much about working with
barbada
is her absolute
dedication to these children i'm sorry
to say
behind the scenes barbados would be the
first one
and the last one first one there and the
last one to leave whenever
there was an extra moment to spend and
you could
you could really see that um
the the dedication and the love that
barbada
uh exudes on screen also carries
off screen crystal tell me what you
loved about working alongside miss
peppermint
oh so much um we had some great musical
moments
while we were getting ready some lovely
janet jackson bonding
i think we wanted a variety of musical
divas which was really fun
but i think um peppermint brings so much
warmth and heart to the competition and
she
is so freaking eloquent just sitting
next to her
and when she's when she's giving a
critique or when she's speaking to one
of her children
it's like a master class in how to
deliver yourself
with warmth and eloquence and
professionalism and then also
behind the scenes peppermint is a boss
[ __ ] and she doesn't take any
and i really respect that you three are
incredible mothers and mentors and you
should all be so proud of yourselves
and i can't wait to keep doing this with
you i hope we keep going i'll be talking
to you about this show for a while
absolutely yes yes please do call me
anytime even if you're not wearing any
clothes or shorts or whatever
but can i call you mother oh you can
call me whatever you want
as long as i can call you daddy call
your first trap
you